because marriage will be the hardest
thing you'll ever do marriage is not
easy raising kids very hard but marriage
is harder you will be more forgiving
with your kids than you will be with
your spouse because your kids are yours
your husband's not yours you can't
replace kids in the mindset you can say
well this doesn't work out but those two
will be very very difficult marriage and
kids so the more things you get up front
I mean if you look at the biggest
decisions we make in life marriage at
the top
having kids
buying a house starting a business you
can go on with all places you put your
kids to school who you befriend all of
these things uh you can't get those big
decisions wrong you can get 19 speeding
tickets fine it's bad you shouldn't do
it I got 21 of them my license has been
suspended a couple times if you can't
avoid driving fast do it she shouldn't
do it but it's not the biggest mistake
in life right biggest decision in life
you can go out there and have jobs in
different Industries you know what you
wear some people have good taste some
people don't have good taste you look at
somebody and like wow I can't believe
he's wearing that I can't believe she's
wearing that and sometimes you look at
somebody like wow I can't believe she's
wearing that looks great on her but
that's great for impression but it's not
one of the biggest decisions in life so
for me it's it's more about you know
sitting down and trying to instill the
values and principles in our house
reading books is extremely critical if
you want anything you want to negotiate
with me it's all about books you got to
read 30 pages a day the moment you turn
six 6 is 20 8 is 30. so our daughter
sent us she knows every day is 20 Pages
including Sundays Mondays Saturdays
vacation Christmas doesn't matter you
have to move your body every day where
you have to go out there and exercise
and a family right now we're taking a
diet very seriously with health so we're
changing a lot we just brought somebody
in to go through the fridge and just
kind of look at what we're doing what
we're not doing so we're kind of
changing that up but again lead respect
improve love those are four things never
bully never get bullied we pray for four
things courage wisdom tolerance
understanding and our affirmation I
Dylan James bet David will one day be a
great leader not I am a great leader I
will one day be a great leader because
you're lying if you say you're a great
leader becoming a great leader takes a
few decades to go through it doesn't
happen overnight by the way when you sit
down and you map that out for your life
and your family and then you sell it and
you hope enough of them buy this is why
I got four kids and not one kid I think
having one kit is the biggest risk
you'll take if I could have 20 kids I
would have 20 kids but my wife's having
the kids I'm not so we stopped at four
but I mean I can go on and on and on a
lot of this is thought out and when you
put it on paper then your job as a
leader just to keep reselling it
re-talking about it representing a
different story that you know validates
one of the points you're making and
you're hoping
enough of it sticks with them my mom has
always told us growing up you guys the
three kids you're a mirror of us whether
you do good you're bad you humiliate
yourself that's fine but you're
humiliating at your family so we grew up
with the mentality whatever we do our
legendary
guilt yes the Armenian Method Man of
leading we all do it to say you know
don't shame our family yeah it's such a
it's such a pride you know thing that
Armenians we have the syrians we have
it's uh by the way it's not everybody no
it's a different kind of a pressure that
is set from the top you know some like
it some don't like it I like high
standards so you know sometime when you
set a high standard like that it doesn't
mean your kids are going to like it all
the time let me say one thing when we
were young I hated it my mom was both my
parents but Mom I'm very strict very
strict like I didn't want to do
something now you're going to do it when
you when you turn a certain age and then
when is your mom's birthday what month
January 20th oh so I always get it wrong
Aries February February February 20
Aquarius born in 19 but they told me
it's 21. I don't know yeah so my wife is
February 14th I've not met an aquarius I
haven't liked in my life yet so they're
very very good people very cool so high
standards great very and I'm very good
how did he do with the standards oh he's
amazing yeah you can tell he's like you
know his car his eyes seem like he's a
very good guy he's an amazing person
yeah you can you can feel his spirit I
don't know about your Puerto Rican son
I'm a little concerned about him or the
German one but I get a very good feeling
about no like my I'm I'm I was just for
full disclosure if you follow this she
does not have a Puerto Rican son we
don't want rumors circulating here
breaking up our marriage Pat said yeah
um no I'm I'm very I think I've hit the
jackpot when it comes to family
touchwood and I think they inspire me
every day they're younger than me but I
look up to them so much um and I
wouldn't be able to do this without them
respect yeah that's great yeah that's
great yeah they're amazing so actually
one more other question was about family
so being a country 10 credit for 15
years now my it's a family business my
dad does all the filming on YouTube
Instagram everything it's so funny I
tell people he's like a 65 year old
Armenian guy and you'll hear us yelling
on the street and people like were they
yelling but you know what we're yelling
about he's like I want to take a photo
in front of this tree I'm like Dad I
don't like this tree no yeah it's this
tree and he goes down no take it I'm
like is he a very big creative is he a
creative musician okay I mean there you
go so we follow the trace all the oh my
God like I don't want you're
embarrassing I'm going to walk away I'm
literally fight over things like that
but
um my mom's my manager she helps me day
to day my brother I have an agency with
a marketing agency called Thomas in
media marketing so it's a family
business so my question is do you have
family involved because I know it can be
tricky and how much of your success
would you contribute to your family or
because I know your sister works with
you I love working with family capable
family yeah but I love working with
family just because your family doesn't
mean we're going to be working together
so the way I set the standards with the
kids uh we're driving the other day and
I asked them I said hey uh Tico Dylan
Senna are you guys wondering gonna want
to be in business with me when you guys
age
he says that that that's pretty
technical question let us think about it
I look at Jen I'm like what you're 10
years old you're nine years old and they
start talking think about it yeah so for
10 minutes they're talking they said
yeah we made a decision that we're
probably going to be in business with
ourselves not with you but we're going
to do a business together I'm like fair
enough I'm like that's fantastic right
because uh my vision with these guys is
to figure out a way for them to do
business together but at the same time
each of them has their own independent
mind yeah you know you don't know what
they're going to be doing they have
their own goals they have their own
Visions they have what they're going to
be doing my ideal situation would be for
all of us to live in a similar
neighborhood there's a family in our
community a very successful billionaire
family in the in an industry that does
very well the oldest son who's the CEO
of the company has the house here
beautiful home the youngest son is here
parents are here both sons have four
kids
both sons are doctors both sons married
a doctor and their family is always
together they were living on the same
street 10 years ago two years ago now
they're living right next to each other
and they're very very close because
certain values and principles they went
through a certain estate planning
company called Ronald blue I don't know
if you've heard of it they do a very
good job I think they manage a very
small amount of families uh one of them
being the Chick-fil-A and so the
structure of the way you build it with
your family when you do estate planning
is hey in this family if you want to get
to this you got to go through these
certain expectations if you don't you
don't have to do it but you're not going
to be participating in XYZ there's
certain set of standards that you got to
go through with the family you can go do
whatever you want to do but these are
some of the guidelines that the family
has they expect you to do this this this
this that right somebody May listen to
this sound like God this is too much
this is ridiculous no wonder you know
Harry married Megan and everybody is
bothering these guys that's exactly why
you know
Etc no no no no this is ours never said
you have to like it but this is ours I
selfishly I'm greedy I would like my
kids to be around me for the rest of my
life because I love kids I would want my
grandkids to be close to me because we
have certain Visions with our family
what we want to do the next 40 years
right so to inject those mindsets into
the kids require them to be close now
again they can do whatever they want to
do but that's part of what we think
about
thank you